Hello
bitches.
Um,
I could ice skate incredibly man.
I'm fucking again.
Ice Skating.
85.
Yeah.
Have a good day.
First of all,
I can't find it.
Shoot when I don't have my own ice
caves,
so I have to rent ice skates.
It's for the same reason why I couldn't
a no go or years.
I can rent.
Those are fucking shitty.
Well it's just that my feet are too
wide.
So if I had a regular size 11 my feet,
I have someone in my background fucked a
monkey when it was big fucking big foot
long time ago.
Like when you shouldn't be able to fuck
monkeys anymore.
Someone just went back in for one more
shot,
fucked a monkey guaranteed.
It was like the last like last call
evolution last car and one of my
ancestors just snuck back in and got one
more nut off.
Um,
but my feet are just too wide,
so I get in those things.
I'm just in agony and it just never
learned how,
and I'm not going to,
I'm just not interesting enough for me
to go out and buy ice skates.
You know,
it feels like this is it.
It's just something I have to conquer
than it would have to learn how to ice
skate as much more satting as a youth.
Yeah.
Fucking roller.
Not Roller blading.
Fucking ice skating to green day shit
like that.
You know what I mean?
That's right.
They play loud music and you spin around
the ice.
Yeah.
See,
I guess hockey would be the reason to do
it.
Like if you wanted to learn how to play
hockey,
you say you pretend you're,
you're doing hockey moves,
you know,
like you're on the ice,
snowing when you stop and you just throw
the snow at people,
you know the show.
Right.
That's,
that's a cool move.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it's like you were the hockey skates.
You definitely don't wear the figure
skating ones.
Mm.
No chance.
No,
you don't.
What's the difference?
Well,
they have the spikes in the front,
so you could do the trip will tell
lunch.
You don't want anybody to let you,
you don't want anybody seeing your
spikes.
You're gonna.
When you go straight,
you have to lift it a little bit and
you're going to fall on your face to
hockey is a little curvature.
Or like a running shoe just allows you
to maneuver to dies.
So it allows you to maneuver better,
but it doesn't allow you to do tricks.
Can't do,
you can't do a stop and then triple til
lunch.
So let go Scott Hamilton flip.
So are they doing flips and when they do
those spins on the ice,
they doing them with like special
skates?
Is that what the deal is?
So sure.
Brian Boitano.
Okay.
And I've noticed with archery,
my ego,
even when I will have me shoot the on
the exact same way,
even though I'm still off the fucking
target,
you know,
like you say,
no,
you were right through Arrow was wrong.
That's how the brain works.
Like it fell right.
Just keep doing it.
So,
so,
so you've got to,
even though the feedback from the
universe is like,
nope,
wrong,
don't take that approach to bud fucking
ever.
Wow,
you hurt somebody or hurt somebody.
Stop screaming.
I'm doing it.
Right.
Yeah,
right.
Exactly.
But think of it,
man.
So I certainly am in my life have erred
by choosing my instinct over the
feedback I'm getting from the universe.
Well,
this is like that book that you
introduced me to,
which I war of art.
Now the book of five rings.
Oh,
the real ones and the one that talks
about how uh,
you should just learn anything like get
good at anything.
It doesn't matter what the thing is that
you're getting good at.
Because if you understand how to get
good at this one thing,
you can extrapolate from that how to get
good at almost anything.
There's these recurring patterns that
happen.
And so with archery it's really cool
because you have to find these,
you have to keep all these variables the
same no matter what your environment,
if you can learn to keep these variables
the same if you're on a hill,
the distance when,
whatever,
if you can learn how to hold these
variables the same,
which is the anchor point,
the way your arm holds the bow,
the way you pull the Arrow back,
the way you release the arrow.
There's all these pieces in there and if
you can keep all of those the same or
close to the same with adjustments based
on whatever your target app is to be,
then you're going to improve in your
accurate accuracy.
If you keep changing your variable,
if you keep moving your arm up or down
or like releasing in a different way or
whatever,
if any of these things are always
changing,
you won't be as accurate over time.
So from that you can grab that and look
at your life and realize like,
Oh shit man,
my wife,
I've just been readjusting all these
stupid variables over and over and over
again without just for at least a month
attempting some rhythmic patterns,
some similar thing,
you know,
and when you start doing that,
it's really interesting because you
begin to,
um,
improve and a lot of an in everything in
general.
I mean there's,
there's arguments in anthropology that
actually there were lots of societies
that had a lot more leisure time than we
do,
you know,
the hunting,
gathering societies and spend,
you know,
four to five hours a day,
quote unquote working hunting,
gathering.
And had lots of time for,
you know,
ceremonies and all kinds of other
things.
It depends on where you are in the world
and how harsh to conditions were,
but,
but the,
you know,
sort of the original leisure society
May,
it may have predated a,
did agriculture.
Certainly they had no i-phones and
maybe,
maybe that was a blessing,
who knows.
But four or five hours of hunting and
gathering is exhausting,
you know,
and you really don't have enough time to
develop a car.
No,
no cars.
Yeah.
After you figured that out,
after you've gotten done,
you're hunting and gathering,
then it's about cooking and,
but also there's no days off because you
don't have any refrigeration.
Right.
Depending on,
you know,
depending on your climate.
I mean,
they could,
they could try things and do certain
things,
but clearly,
clearly not a,
not a frigidaire.
I'm around the corner.
Oh.
But you know what you're talking about
about whether it's cities or just modern
society,
that
high tech,
high speed world that most of us live
in,
where many of us don't feel like we have
much free time and we're running around
and doing all these things in cities.
Usually,
uh,
when I talked to people who become
hunters as adults
by and large,
that's part of why they did it.
They want it to reconnect.
Yeah.
It's part of why they garden.
It's part of why they raised chickens.
It's part of why they do all sorts of
other things that you understand and,
and value to.
They want to get back in touch with
those.
Not only the hands on skills but just
the world they inhabit.
You know,
beyond the domesticated concretized city
conquered types,
you know,
the pavement,
beyond the payment into nature and
whether it's a little garden patch in
your backyard or you know,
hunting around the Missouri breaks,
you know,
there's a sense of wanting to reconnect
so that all of these practices,
hunting,
gardening,
raising chickens in part are like an
antidote,
modern life.
So do you want to,
you want me to tell you a bit about the
evolutionary roots of religion,
how you would study religion as an
evolutionist?
Okay.
You Ready?
Yeah.
So one argument is based on,
it's an adaptive argument,
right?
So the idea is if religion exists,
does it confer an adaptive advantage to
people?
And so there is some work done by a good
friend of mine,
Dave Wilson,
Wilson and evolutionary biologists who
are,
he argues using a groups selectionists
argument that that groups that are
religious out survive groups that are
not by virtue of them being more
communal,
more cohesive,
more abandoned.
So that argument is an adaptive argument
for why religion exists.
There is another argument by other
evolutionists that is based on an
exaltation argument.
Have you ever heard that term?
Exactly.
What does that mean?
So that's a byproduct of evolution.
In other words,
it's something that evolved,
not because itself,
it confers an adaptive advantage,
but rather it's piggy backing.
So for example,
the fact that your skeletal system,
is it the color that it is,
that itself is not adaptive.
It is a byproduct of other evolutionary
processes.
So from that perspective,
religion piggy backs on computational
systems in our brains that evolved for
other things,
if all what I mean.
So for example,
coalitional thinking the idea of viewing
the world as us versus them,
the team versus red team,
that is an innate part of our psychology
now.
Now religion piggybacks on that,
right?
It takes that computational system that
already exists in us and it,
it puts it on steroids,
right?
So you thinking about the Abrahamic
religions,
right?
Every one of them has us versus them.
They are the Jews,
the gentiles,
the believers,
the Kuffar,
right?
Uh,
and so,
uh,
agency detection detecting agency and
things is something that is innate to
us.
Religion plays on that.
The agent becomes God.
And s.
So that's an argument that was proposed
by Pascal boy where he's basically
saying that religion did not
specifically evolve because itself,
it is adaptive,
but it's piggy backs on other things
that have evolved.
And then a third way to study religion
is to just do a content analysis of the,
the,
the narratives within religion.
So there's a great study done by a
Darwinian historian where she looked at
in the old testament how many women are
ascribed to a different male and the old
and the Old Testament as a function of a
status.
So the higher the status of the male,
the more sexual partners he had,
which is exactly what you would predict
from an evolutionary perspective.
High status to men confers reproductive
success.
So there are different ways that
evolution is,
and there are several other ways that
can study religion from an evolutionary
perspective.